colas de más de un kilómetro y familias
ansiosas esperando en sus autos estos
son los residentes que huyen de gerson
la ciudad se ha convertido en un
objetivo permanente de los ataques rusos
desde su retirada hace dos semanas
no ve otro camino tras tres o cuatro
días después de que abandonaron gerson
empezaron Los Fuertes bombardeos muchas
personas murieron y otras resultaron
heridas los rusos están disparando al
centro de la ciudad a las casas a todo
antes de ayer la artillería golpeó mi
casa cuatro pisos fueron quemados las
ventanas se rompieron no podemos estar
allí el viernes jerson sufrió su
bombardeo más mortífero con 15 muertos
el Gobierno ucraniano no tiene más
opción que evacuar a los que quieren
irse y las autoridades habilitaron
trenes de emergencia para llevar a los
residentes a otras regiones del país
empezaron a aterrorizarnos golpeaban de
forma caótica no tenían objetivos
militares solo apuntaban a zonas
residenciales
posicionadas Al otro lado del río nipro
las fuerzas rusas también habían atacado
infraestructuras clave dejando a los
residentes sin electricidad Pero las
autoridades ucranianas han conseguido
restablecer la electricidad en la ciudad